my name is felonious Floyd brother Josh
Floyd we come up together we didn't have
much
our mom did what she could we would
sleep in the same bed play video games
together go outside and you know play
catch with the football and I used to
say to myself like man you can't throw
you can't throw at all you know I mean
because the ball never came to me and uh
years down the line because I was
catching with one hand two hands anyway
you threw it I started being able to
catch it he said I can throw but I just
wanted you to go get the ball the ball
don't need to come to you you need to go
get the ball
but you know my brother we did a lot of
things together from like talking with
my mom dancing with my mom cooking with
our mom brothers and sisters so much we
made banana mayonnaise sandwiches
together you know it was it was a family
thing you know everyday we know when we
come in the house our mom was gonna have
a huge plate of food separate from each
other and we were sit there and I'll go
with you said who played it was and I'm
like in like ten I live in I'm talking
about the plate with six pieces of
chicken his mind and he way bigger than
me
you know man he's huge so ma'am from
from that being in the house with my
brother man it was just like inspiring
to other people because my mom used to
take in other kids and most of them was
George's friends and they wanted to stay
with her they loved her you know and my
brother he was okay with it so Dean you
had three to me they were grown din
because they kicked me out the room they
were three men like 1617
groans sleeping in the same bed waking
up going to the same school and they
wouldn't leave each other at all they
always wanted to be with each other at
all times
I remember nights when the day before
school we didn't have a washing machine
so we would all go in and put our socks
and underwear in a bathroom sink and
just start washing them watching them
and we didn't have detergent we would
use soap but we were watch it was gonna
be clean Oh get clean so we would
literally then right after that we would
take the socks and hang them over the
hot water heater and we would take the
underwear and hang them over there and
we will fight about it me and his
friends and all of you like no no no no
you did it last night because your
clothes probably still be dumped the
next day if you don't put it on a hot
water heater so from from there and we
learn a lot of stuff but it's crazy
because we would like we didn't have a
dryer so the fastest way to dry your
clothes was to put it in the oven and
let it let it dry faster like that so it
was Jen's van I love my brother man we
had so many memories you know together
I remember him waking me up telling me
hey man can you iron my clothes for me
and I look at him but then I look at his
side and I say you right big bro you
right it was just it was just amazing
everywhere you go and see people how
they cling to him they wanted to be
around him you know George he was like a
general every day he walks outside it'd
be a lot of people like just like we
came in wanting to greet him and wanted
to have fun with him guys that was doing
drugs like smokers and homeless people
you couldn't tell because when you spoke
to George
they felt like they was the president
because that's how he made you feel he
was he was powerful man he had a way
with words he could always make you
ready to
and go all the time everybody loves
George we didn't call him George
we called him Peary if you if you called
him Perry you knew him
diary you know because George was the
name everybody called a big George a big
Floyd you know Georgie Porgie he had so
many different names but I'm gonna go
here and let im just man it's crazy man
all these people came to see my brother
and that's amazing to me that he touched
so many people hearts you know cuz he
been touching our hearts you know you
come to third war where we're from
people are crying right now that's how
much they love them you know I'm just
staying strong as I can because I need
to get it out I need to get it out
everybody won't justice we want justice
for George he's gonna get it he's gonna
get it
you